をナムです0て前とるわ
great pleasure フォア3 to address this 時
シングリッシュ
をディアス2 day みなさんこんにちは
じゃあであの今日お話ししたいことはあのあれから5年だったんで最初行ったのは
2010年のトレック東京だったんですけど
あれから5年間私が何をどういう活動をしてきたかということ今何に関心を持っている
かということ
それから将来こんなことをしたいということその3つ
話していければと思ってますであのはその一つがあの
iphone アプリしなさんというのあのカーフしたという事ですそれであの今これ
はあの大変号がしまして
英語中国語韓国語でもあの対応しております
どうぞご覧ください
それからあの時にもお話したんですけどもあの excel 後もかなりあの
よろ工夫して改良しまして今ここに来ているブラウスもあの
自分で作った方ですというようなことであの多い
あのを楽しめますので今はあのね本国ないとか
海外でワークショップをやって皆さんにこれをご紹介しております
それから私がね17位からかかってきた
あのシニアの高住サイトメロクランもおかげさまで20周年を迎えました
そして相変わらず自主運営で頑張ってます
それからあんまあのネットブロガーのスクール教会前つくであの子ニャのあの
デー猿復帰の道央習得の豪雪ぽ手伝いやあのご相談にも乗っています
まだあとあの色でやってまして地方創生とあのう
大人の再教育のためのプロジェクトね中小学校の先生をしたりその他
あちこちをあの日本語を久住時な海外もあの
飛び回って
干支広連会などをやっておりますまたあのし視野の自立支援を+事実を助ける
先端技術の本が機会もあの当事者としていろいろ体験したり本も書いてますで今関心を
持っているのはあの海外の人たちがこういうことをどう
ふうに感じているかということでどんな風にあのう
海外の信者私が it と取り組んでいるかということでそれをまず知るために
あの今年の6月でエストニアに行ってまいりました
ですニャでいろいろ勉強したんですけれどもあの皆さんのお陰てあの犬のことができ
ました
特にあのとアンケートをやらせていただいて
でエストニアのシニア受信が米誌政府である自分の国その電子行政をどう評価している
かということを本でお聞きました
驚きましたことにあの
すでにアンケートにコゼーてくださった方の8週5%があの電子政府のサービスを常し
ている
しかもその中の95%の人はこれが非常に役に+便利で
パスクアルいつかあそう覚め優しいということで非常に肯定的なあの反応を示していく
勝ったことそれからもう一つはあの私は一体どうやって it を習得したんですかと
いう質問に対して
by myself 自分で独習しましたっていう方が1は多かったというのが非常に
あの
考えを受けました
者がポンドはお願いですあのまずあのメーカーの方にお願いなんですけども
あの子ニャーが使いやすい企業でいい開発してください
それからあのコンテンツを作ってくださっている方にお願いします
シリアが楽しめるようなあのコンテンツをたくさん作ってくださいそれから
通信会社の方にお願いしますあの子ニャはスマートフォン中の利用量が非常に少ないの
で
であのそういう工具治療兆候うちの店のあの料金体系も考えてください
それからあのう
行政の方にをお願いしますあのーとまずは誰が勉強する場というのがだんだん減ってき
ております場所の覚悟
願いしますそれからあの i 高齢者向け it 支援員ですが早ければを助けばこれ
はこれからますます重要になってくると思うんですそして
これからは色々なデジタル機も対応化し
してきますですから導入のあの相談から初期設定に至るまであの背を押してくださる
あのお助けマンがこれから重要な異名を示してくると思うんです
目線ですよあの供給する側と新アート
業製造があの
を情報交換できる web サイトを是非ご用意いただければと思います
それからまあご家族の方よく手伝ってあげてください
それからあのお願いするが悪化しちゃダメだと思うんです私達も何か
あの
社会に貢献したいでどんなことで貢献できるかいろいろ考えたんですけど今考えている
のが時々版 hand
要するにあの年を言ってるのは
年上に大柄を者そんなにえませんけど古賀茂明結構居るわけですそれでそういう人が
まあ50万円ある100万円を固執する
もちろん出資ですから不幸にして戻ってこないこともありますけれども
でそのお金をあの後れプレイヤーの方に使っていただいて
でいろいろ先端
恐喝していただきたいであのまあその義務としてはまあ
深夜でもよくわかる企画書を作っていただ
多分若い方もっとよくわかると思うんですそれからあのその後のあの進捗状況を定期的
にご報告いただきたい
4番大切なことをなんですけどもしもうまくいっ
いかなかった時にはあのと出版報告書
詳細の失敗を置く書を出していただきて
と申しますのはあのシュッパイのデータというのは非常に他の方でも役員いたしますの
で個人情報を除いてデータですからそういうことも参考になると思うんです
で
あの軟骨私を84年間の経験で一番役に立ったのはやっぱし
あの出版の体験だったですただ失敗の体験とが大事にしていきたいというのが私の希望
です
維持ですよあのー
視野がいろんなあの木をうまく使いこなせるようにそして死にゃあの自立のために先端
きや
役に立っていくようにあのご来場の皆様のご支援をお願いいたします本日はありがとう
ございました